أحتاج حقًا إلى السؤال عن المقترحات الخمسة ،
هل صحيح أنك اقترحتها خمس
مرات وما الذي فازت به في النهاية
أو أكثر من
[موسيقى]
عندما خرجت مع أول مرة
عرفت فيها أن هذه هي المرأة التي فعلتها حقًا ، لذا
فأنت تؤمن بالحب  للوهلة الأولى ، أفعل ذلك
في ليلتي الأولى مرتين فقط في حياتي
، لقد وقعت في الحب في كل مرة ، وفي
المرتين اللذين عرفت فيهما على الفور
[موسيقى]
ولداي هما أولاد "نحن صغار" وقد
جاءوا وقلت أن
أبي وهانت قد قاما بتحويل  الكرة وقال بو
أنت تخبرهم ولا تخبرهم أنك
ستجد قلت ما الأمر يا رفاق
بوفورت قال أبي نحن نتحدث نعتقد
أننا يجب أن نتزوج جيل جيدًا أنت تعلم أنه
يجب أن أتأكد تمامًا من أن هذا
الزواج كان على وشك  للعمل
لأنهم فقدوا والدتهم وفقدوا
أختهم وعرفت
أنه كان علينا العمل لأنني فقدت
الكثير من
[موسيقى]
شيء واحد يقدمه لي جو كل عام
وهو قصيدة عرفتك "  أحب
أن يكون لديه كتاب اشتراه لي
وفي كل عام يكتب صفحة  oem أنت
شخصيًا تكتب
القصيدة بالطبع أفعل الكثير لأكتب عنها